a big fan of this man's work a very big
fan of this man's work and i could not
be more pleased that he's uh
included our show on the tour that we
have seen him make uh over the last
couple of days
uh in support of his new film that he
has written
that he has directed uh and he acts in
it's a beautiful film that is available
in theaters
on digital and on demand this very
friday the written a writer and
directorial debut
of the tremendous actor viggo mortensen
who's here on the show how are you vigo
i'm good thanks for inviting me i'm i'm
pleased to have you on this program um
before we get to your movie i do want to
hit you if you don't mind right away
um with a story um that i heard uh
of you tell on other spots and i'd love
for you to uh tell my audience as well
uh starting you're from watertown new
york correct
that's where you're we're born
technically i was born
no i was born in new york city you're
born but
my mother's from watertown new york okay
and my uh
after my parents put up i spent my she
went back to her hometown with me
my two brothers and we from the age of
11
through high school and lived there you
lived in central new york is that how
you made your way to lake placid on
february 22nd 1980
vigo yeah that's correct i was there
during the whole olympics as a
as a volunteer what were you doing at
the winter olympics the
the 1980 olympics what were you
volunteering doing
well i was going to college nearby uh
in canton new york saint lawrence
university and um
uh january was oh
and i got a permission to go do this you
know
i got i volunteered a couple other
people i think from there did too
too i was supposed to translate for the
danish you know team
cross-country skiers i guess they ended
up not coming i guess they didn't think
they just put a chance they didn't want
to spend
the energy and the money i don't know
right and so i said uh well if you want
to translate for the swedes then i said
okay
i mean neither of the swedes know the
danes really needed that much help to
speak english really well maybe
you know i told him some swear words i
guess but i just
i just ran errands and you know got him
stuff and
hung out and got you know these great
athletes amazing athletes and uh
the best thing about the whole
experience for me
was that i got to be friends with people
on the finish team
uh finland's team and um
they said if you ever want to see a
hockey game i said yeah
can i go to go to one they go sure and
then the next day i won again and they
said anytime you want to come i said
great so i went there
every night to go see hockey and uh we'd
stop at the fin
finland house each country had their
house where they sort of had tourist
pictures and some of their products and
in the finland house it was pretty much
just vodka
so we'd have a few drinks and go to the
game really in a good mood and and
uh yes i saw i saw the united states
uh do the impossible with these college
players these kids really
beating what was probably at that time
the greatest hockey team
on the planet so union so normally i i'd
want to immediately delve into this
part of the story and i and i will uh if
you don't mind
uh i will put a pin in it for the moment
so are you saying you've done
uh vodka shots with yari curry at the
1980 olympics is that what you're saying
to me vigo mortensen that actually
happened no he
oh no yari i didn't i didn't drink with
him i think he was on his best behavior
at least as far as
but uh no it was like other people in
the delegations
okay here and the people and you know
yeah
oh holy crap i mean did well too i think
didn't they get
didn't they get third place well no they
were in the middle
they they the u.s actually there was a
gold medal game everybody thinks that
when they beat the soviets that's right
right everybody thinks that when they
play the final with them exactly the
silvia game is the final
right of course so then where were you
actually where were your seats inside
that arena
viggo where were your seats um man it
wasn't it was
pretty center along the side and uh
i'd say i can't remember maybe
maybe eight rows back 10 rows back it
was they were great seats actually they
were really really good
um so it was it was an amazing thing you
know i didn't think they would win it
but i thought they would give them a
good
you know because you're playing at home
in front of your you know
your fans your country and i knew they
would be feisty and just give it all but
i figured you know there's no way
and lo and behold it's a miracle
can you do your best if you don't mind i
mean you clearly are
uh a storyteller of note uh again your
film falling we'll talk about your
your writing and directorial debut but
you're you know what it takes to tell a
great story and and obviously
emote um a great story what can you
describe for me what it was like
in that arena that night i mean
walk me through it well it became
bedlam but it was there was this growing
before they even passed them you know in
the scoring
there was just this this hum
you know you had this this sensation
that wow
maybe well nah it won't but they're
giving them a game
you know we thought it'd be like to get
their clocks clean
probably a lot of people and they
weren't
they were given as good as it got in
every area of the game
and it just kept growing it was a
feeling
it kept growing and i you know the last
part of the
game everybody's on their feet and i was
just it was tremendous it was an amazing
sensation and after the game was over i
still couldn't believe it
just it was incredible it was just
incredible
do you have the ticket stub i didn't
need vodka
do you have do you feel the cold when
they went outside i bet
did you did you have a stub or uh you
got the bronze right did sweden get the
bronze
i i think the soviets dusted them off i
think the soviets might have gotten the
bronze i'm i'm
you know what i i i remember i've kind
of lost track on that but do you have a
stub or a program from that still
or any memento from that day i'm taking
my i wish i did
i wish i did i have my i have my uh
volunteer
you know laminated path that i have
with the lake classic symbol on it on a
little cord or string i think
i have that stowed away i don't have the
ticket
i'm so stupid i should have kept that
well who the heck knows right years
later
yes you're uh sweden did in fact win the
bronze in the 1980 olympics
yeah that's right viggo mortensen here
on the rich eisen show so did uh
i imagine uh i i was happy for them
because i was supposed to be working for
them you know so
what do you mean the family's got the
sweets i mean oh
technically of course sweden not to be
cheering for the united states blowing
on the glass if you had gotten a seat so
close you know so are you a hockey guy
would you say that's your sport that you
follow or at all
or what i'm a habs fan when i
i grew up most the first decade of my
life in argentina so
football soccer was was was and
is the sport i like them the most
probably but right next to it or just as
much i like i like hockey when i moved
to
northern new york state up by the
canadian border
in 1970 i lost contact of course there
was no internet or
iphones or any of that stuff back and
there wasn't even cable tv yet
and there's only a couple of channels
you know a local regional i think
there's a cbs and an nbc
and then there was across the way there
was a canadian channel
and i started to see this sport and it
was montreal canadians it was their
heyday the 70s
so i started watching them play and had
same colors as my soccer team
and uh and the fans are pretty rabid
uh you know from montreal and i i was
looking i thought this is a great sport
this is like soccer but
a lot faster and with sticks and you can
beat it out of people
and there's no there's no there's not a
lot of flapping there's there's there's
there's just a lot more grinding than
flopping
you know yeah and it was it was terrific
you know gila fleur and all those other
players that was that was their
legendary the golden age really
and uh one of them but uh yeah so that's
how i became
a hockey fan and and you know followed
them ever since yeah ken dryden was on
the call with al michaels on that
miracle on ice night in 1980 i mean he's
here i mean you're you're talking about
liz abby tone as you refer to canadians
as the
as the habs of vigo mortensen here on
the right to uh
one last thing oh go please um yeah
their 100 year anniversary was uh
december 4th
2009 and i got and they knew i was a fan
so they invited me up to the
to montreal to the bell center
and uh to you know they were gonna all
the
legends that were still alive you know
in wheelchairs however they could get
there
all came you know wearing sweaters and
um
and gila fleur was one of them he was my
idol from back then
and uh and they asked me i said well
we'd like you to present one of the
legends
if you want before they do their skate
around and everything else
i said anyone i want and i said sure you
know if he's not taken
and i guess it was early enough that he
wasn't taken i said how about you
lafleur and they said done
so he got to present guiller on
center ice at the at the bell center
that was a highlight
come on that is so cool that is
that is so incredible viggo mortensen
here on the rich eisen show
let's talk about your film falling um
and
and uh you you wrote that is this true
you wrote this on a on a plane flight or
you began to
write it and then it's now come into
this beautiful film with you
and lance henriksen who's a dynamite
actor that so many people
have seen from uh from aliens or
or the right stuff from back in the day
and laura linney what a heck of a cast
for your
writing and directorial debut vigo yeah
i couldn't have
had a better cast very fortunate very
very happy to have them and uh lance
henderson gives an unforgettable
performance
he's astounding really disturbing
sometimes
no holds barred he's just terrific i
couldn't
imagine anyone else doing it better i
think it's a performance that'll
stand the test of time it'll live long
in memory
and uh by the way there is a nod to gila
fleur i had to get permission from his
family and from the nhl but there's a
diner scene
if you look closely on the wall there's
a picture of your floor
it takes place in the 70s great great
easter egg anyway
but um yeah i was uh
it was right after my mother died in
2015
and she had had dementia for several
years like
like lance's character does in the movie
and you know when someone dies you
really love they're very present
everything about them images of their
you know my mom's face
from different periods and stories about
her that i could remember
and shared with my brothers and that
other people had their versions of the
same stories of the funeral which i
thought was strange how subjective
memory is you know and then new stories
from
old people that i've known are in the
childhood that i've never met
and so i just wanted to remember that i
want to keep it alive so i'm flying back
long plane flight overnight and um
when i started writing down these things
and i looked at what i was writing down
so this big good story so i wrote as a
short story on this plane and wrote the
whole thing out
you know fast and um and then i put it
aside because
i was at the time i was trying to get
another screenplay made into a movie
i've been trying for 25 years to make a
movie as a director
from different screenplays and so and
one day i thought i should read that
thing i wrote on the plane it's probably
not that great
it's like when you wake up in the middle
of night if you have a notepad by your
bed you
you scribble some lying down or some
idea you have maybe
and then the next days like oh that was
great yeah let me see that and it's
usually not very great it's like
oh i wrote a story and i was drunk and
it was brilliant and then you read it
it's like no
right and but this actually was good
it was had a really good structure the
basic structure that the movie had
and all these different points of view
memories from the father's point of view
the kid's point of view and it
it isn't my mother's the character that
plays my mother in the story
was kind of like my mother but that's
that's the only real thing
right one of the only the few things
that are resemble our actual family i
mean it's a fiction i ended up
feeling career didn't have to check with
anybody in the family about facts
just making up a story but based on the
feelings i had from my mom and to some
degree from my dad
and um i looked at it
it's very visual i can see these memory
shots and all these things that
i'm describing in the story maybe it's a
movie instead of a book you know
and so i started uh i wrote that
screenplay out when the other movie fell
apart i started the process of trying to
get this name it took me
about four years and i got lance
hendrickson on board
fortunately early on and and he to his
credit he stuck it out
through second thing you know lost the
money a couple times and we finally
pulled it together you know i called
them when they said hey we're going to
finally make the movie which which was a
lie i didn't have the money
to decide i'm going to pretend like i'm
making it and many other people it'll be
contagious
which kind of happened i just spent a
little money i just said to the
cinematographer that i want to work with
um someone i worked with before a guy
from denmark really good
um artist and i said bring the camera
let's go find this phone let's go find
these locations let's start filming
because i want to have images
for the memories from spring summer fall
you know
different seasons because it's really
nature is really important in the
memories of the father and the son
so we just started and then eventually i
did find a co-producer in canada
and another english guy and we got it
together
but even even when we i wanted to have
seven weeks which is not a lot
five days a week you know 35 days to
shoot all that stuff
in the winter with kids and their
limited hours and you know
short day light hours and all that is
ambitious but
they get the producer said all we can
get is five weeks i said oh man
okay well so we figured out we got a
really good team together we prepared
really well
and then what were just a short ways
from starting to shoot
and the producer comes over and says the
corporation says that
i'm sorry but we only have enough for
two weeks i said well that's impossible
i can't shoot this in two weeks because
yeah but
we'll get the rest probably eventually
it's it's in the works but
right now you actually have enough money
for two weeks do you want to wait till
next year i said no i've been waiting
you know
four years right yeah and four years on
this one so
let's start we got a great team i
couldn't think of a better cast
i mean it's perfect from the littlest
kid up to lance henderson they're all
perfect for their roles who knows if
i'll ever get this together so let's
just start here
okay well there's a risk i said that's
all right and so we got really into it i
was going great
you know in two weeks then i'd
completely forgotten about that
conversation
and he comes over to me one day i'm
standing outside
um between setups and it was kind of
cold and snowing he says hey listen can
i talk to you for a minute i go sure
what's up mangoes
um well you can finish i go finish yeah
you mean today because no no i mean you
can finish the movie i said of course
we're going to finish it well it's going
great
and he goes um no i mean you have enough
money
to finish the movie oh yeah you have
enough money for five weeks now so great
thank you so that's how that went action
then you just call action and then you
just go back to doing it and it is just
so
it's a beautiful movie vigo and people
with with parents who who suffer from
dementia
will recognize a lot of the uh
signposts and and and moments that are
are
heartbreaking and also um i guess what's
the word for it uh exasperating
and um well yeah and the problems that
any um
there's hardly any family doesn't have
some communication problems some
disagreements and this one obviously the
son and the father
they butt heads a lot and have their
whole lives together probably
and that makes it even harder you know
he's not an old man who wants any help
from anybody
he's just a tough bastard and he's he's
really offensive
to people you know he just pushes people
away he's isolated and he's
bitter and he seems to want it that way
and yeah he's my dad so i want to help
him and i realized to help him i'm
probably the only person he'll accept
even
minimal help from right but but in order
to help him so he doesn't
shut me off i ha i'm gonna have to take
i say to him i'm like you know you're
gonna tell me all you want
i want to help you dad so i'm not gonna
i promise myself i'm not gonna get into
another big blowout with you
um you know have at it but i'm not
responding to that so he tries and most
of the money he manages to hang in there
because he realizes i want to help him
i'm gonna have to take a lot of crap and
he does
over and over again until it finally
just blows up and
that it it's it's a movie that i didn't
think of it at the time when i started
writing it but it's become
unfortunately in some ways really timely
because
what's happening in a lot of families
not to mention in society as a whole in
our country
obviously is that we're at an all-time
high as far as people not talking to
each other
and people not communicating well
obviously it's not just politicians
it's just people in the country you know
and we have to sort of try to remember
just like this family and falling does
let's think back
at a time when we actually could talk
and sort of listen to each other at
least a little
and work things out you know make some
deals
try to just just listen to people that
you don't agree with at least
give them a chance and hopefully they'll
give you a chance
we've got to get back to that you know
and so it feels very timely in that
regard too i think a lot of people
know that feeling of why can't i talk to
my friends anymore
why can't i talk to some people my
family more over some
you know political thing or something
that's just ridiculous
falling again in theaters on digital and
on-demand this friday
um viggo before i let you go uh out of
all the films and people that you have
acted with and i i would love if you
don't mind to give me a gene hackman
story you might have
from crimson tide he turned 91
over the weekend do you got do you have
a good gene hackman story that you can
share
well that was an awesome experience both
watching gene hackman and denzel
washington right
was great i i lived near the studio
where we were shooting and i didn't work
every day
and then like a supporting part but on
my days off i went all the time just to
watch those two go at it
as as artists as actors it was like like
a boxing match verbally it was
it was really cool i learned a lot
watching those guys and and he
seen hackman was uh he was crusty
but he was always i mean he was
always on the set always talking with
the crew always hanging out he had a
little dog if you remember in that movie
uh yes his character had a little dog on
the submarine and he was just hanging
out with the dog
drinking coffee with the with the grips
and the people there and just hanging
out he never went to his trailer and
hung out whereas
you know other actors often do that he
was just always on the set
always interested in what's happening
always mentally getting ready
but just relaxing and enjoying the
company people and that's that's my kind
of actor i've always
i think that's why i wanted to direct
i've always liked the collective aspect
the team
aspect of making movies i always thought
it was
it was great to see how you could take
something written down
to the screen and what is that journey
all these different people with
different skills
when it works when it's well led and
people communicate well
it's amazing to see what people can do
they can turn a so-so script into a
great movie and i've seen
really great scripts turn out badly as
movies because people
didn't communicate in that way but tony
scott was a was very good communicator
that was a great crew and and gene
hackman yeah
he's just he was a master is a master
in his art form and so he was at the top
of his game
at that time i think i know what you
mean by krusty but what do you mean by
krusty
to call him crosstalk um he didn't
suffer fools i mean he was just
uh i don't mean crusty old i just know
he was like
you know he was you know a former marine
and a and just a just a tough
guy and at fair but tough you know he
didn't
you know he hated anybody sucking up to
him or
interrupting him or anything like that
so it was like
he had to be on guard and respectful and
just like
watch him and learn basically and just
watching him and denzel go at it is what
you're saying just watching them in
there i love that
yeah it was really great it was fun to
watch sparks were flying
that's for sure and was it always hot on
the set because it or they were just
putting perspiration on you
in between does it look pretty it was
sort of warm but they were mostly
yeah i mean tony's got seems to love
that ridley scott too
of course so sweaty i'm sure
but uh yeah in a submarine it is
actually you know it is tends to be
very warm and so that made sense to a
degree i just figured i'd ask those
questions
yeah yeah yeah it's very sweaty right i
bet and yeah
and i guess he's trying to emphasize the
stress of
my nuclear weapons and you know
everything that was going on in that
story
vigo thank you for the call i hope to do
this again for the next time that you uh
you know have a movie coming out that um
that you want to talk about or any other
any other time i'm a big fan thank you
for the call thank you so much good
go habs there we go go halves there you
go
and uh but a toronto maple leaf fan
you'll still love falling don't don't
don't hold that against him
uh thanks for the well yeah yeah take
care of ego that's viggo mortensen
the writer and director and actor
three-time oscar nominee
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here